[Music]
and Bitcoin strippers news how do you
make them Raymond Vic inches is this in
Las Vegas okay I heard of this awful
rail tell me the details submitted by
Bart's what do you armpits no really so
you one of those have nobody nobody
order no he has body odor just not on
his armpits [ __ ] smells but my hair
it smells pretty bad
you don't need this [ __ ] doesn't stink
gets all oily spills five minutes later
it's [ __ ] stank I love it depends on
what I eat
do you have an urn smell I don't know
cuz I never smelt it are you serious oh
then you probably don't if you never
smell that you smell it oh you get some
on your own yeah oh [ __ ]
I'm selling I don't know when I'm gonna
dance I'm just like some like deodorant
and they were very using that oh yeah
they would do that yeah there's like
ways oh yeah Las Vegas strippers are not
like something Bitcoin via temporary QR
code tattoos Wow penis babies get your
money put on your ass that's Martin just
bend over Billy once all your nipples
have it see that you want to see oh
they're smart Thank You strippers are so
precise genius wait good for them but
Vega strippers make a lot of money huh
damn why are we here
right why can't we all just be strippers
all of us say that all the time I wish I
could see your stripper moves oh I got
moves girls my hips more these days do
that at City
now how do you do that I know [ __ ]
engage them hips girl Wiggly 101
oh it just must be so wet right now
that's really young girl [ __ ] take it
[Laughter]
this story is about the legends room in
Las Vegas is that it's a strip club and
it looks like this on the inside with no
strippers that was nice what all strips
exactly the same it is [ __ ] what do mean
cuz there's a pall in every room yeah
like the lights of couches all look the
same you gotta make them look good
dim light makes everyone like the sexy
this is an example of the temporary
tattoo of their communities that is
genius oh my god I really did that my
friend and best it into this yeah I
think they released it during the
Mayweather fight around there
I don't know the specifics behind it but
it's like this whole concept and
everything you should do it for like
waitresses and the casinos and stuff too
yeah oh no they just give them chips
just like the l1 yeah they even have a
Bitcoin ATM where you can buy bitcoins
you need a wallet for the cryptocurrency
currency I don't know but I think it's
time to buy more Bitcoin that's what it
is
hey Can somebody stripper it drop down
like 60 a couple like a week ago 10,000
right now or something like that oh it's
gone my family but surely yeah and then
also if you pay with cryptocurrency you
get a 20% discount discounts at a strip
club cuz they know it's probably gonna
go up it's like two-for-one deals that
means is even better than cash usually
credit and then cash you get a discount
but this is even more than cash this is
even better than cash yeah so the
strippers are saying that they love it
because once they go to the bank to try
to like deposit all their cash certain
banks will say no and like they'll even
close the account because I know I ain't
made no sense to me to know this exact
money is money how could they close your
account that's [ __ ] up it could be
every time the depositing is it's over
10 grand and it's happening too many
times yeah there's a cake ambassador if
it's if it's cash over 10 grand they
don't close your account it just sends a
red flag to see what kind of like
transactions you're doing and why it is
it combina red flags can you get those I
showed up every single day with 10 G's
that's a big red for maybe you would
definitely give us all the laws that's
called the wire act which was
administered by I think Bush Senior and
that was to stop drug dealers so
anything over $10,000 if you deposit
everything or if you make purchases over
$10,000 they have to report that well
thank God I never had to worry about
that right and if you can't back if you
can't back it up and then the IRS comes
or whatever that you can't back up all
those track cash transactions I think
that's why they're doing it legally but
they're not reporting it leaving so
everyone here can have legal businesses
but evade taxes and do it illegally
right so that's probably what's
happening the match is full of money
yeah and then for me I'd be worried
about all the paper cut if I'm just
getting all these dollars in my [ __ ]
can you imagine how many [ __ ] cuts
you have on those butt cheeks that's not
cool man
no wonder girls have stripper dust on
old bills always pretty done yeah
[ __ ] see the foundation in the belly
they got like an inch layer I know why
they're trying to protect themselves
from the man yeah I guess I would Falls
God do that too you know those clear
stripper heels I think we're the last
ones there you don't worry that just for
looks they wear that so that they're
there the heels grip onto the pole
better oh really
straps are plastic oh no I do white
clear though why don't they get the same
oh no think there's some there's like
plastic with like black or whatever but
that may be the materials grip here
that's clear hmm I thought it was
because they want you to see everything
even their souls I've seen sexy souls
clear stripper heels with like a
platform right and there's like a slot
that says tips knees put in there who
like a piggy bank platform yeah that's
[ __ ] dope every time I see like a
really good strip show or whatever and
then the legs spread like this I'm like
oh you're so talented
oh I got your Crazy Horse yeah the
crazier host girls were really but it
looked like a [ __ ] flower just blue
is this horny ballet what the [ __ ] am i
watching right now damn it's mixing my
heart to get like it's going crazy right
now this does bull dancers dude it's
[ __ ] talent man it's hard stuff it's
a lot of training mm-hmm yep sure a lot
of people can't do its art when you have
a different mix of emotions I think if
it's just one note like my big heart I'm
horny then it's not art so that's the
difference between like a burlesque like
choreograph show like you go through
different movements you're like Oh scary
Oh sad oh no no no you so awesome
excited you know you go through
movements but they're still [ __ ]
involved but then like when it's just
straight nasty porn or whatever this
like oh it's jack off our it's not art
it's like let me get a nut off mmm this
strip club they also have their own
cryptocurrency called LGB that's the one
my friend was doing gentleman's dick
long gentleman's dick long gentleman's
mm-hmm that sounds way better yeah so
they're saying that in the beginning
when they opened this club back in me
last year that I know what it is does he
do ladies get that ladies get dollars
ladies get knowledge not good don't want
ladies get dollars well this is a new
strip club yeah they're saying that in
the beginning it was just a lot of
Bitcoin guys cuz they're like cool like
we can actually spend this here and so
that's how it kind of grew in popularity
damn that means you've been just gonna
get real rich
I remember when I went to a strip club
in Vegas there was a Bobby stripper
how do you know she was Bobby but my
friends frequented Street strip clubs a
lot when I was like 21 this is the first
one everyone see right and she's like hi
honey you wanted them you think I'm
pretty and I was like no [ __ ] way
like my [ __ ] auntie just walked up to
me I bet you those hella dudes that get
horny off of that [ __ ]
she's just telling people did they do
the one dances are not my friend he's
like this High Roller guys I hear here's
some [ __ ] money just shut the [ __ ] up
and give me a show or a dance and don't
talk and then from what my girlfriend
says she went back recently cuz she goes
back and forth to Vegas to strip but
she's like she's still there and she
makes most of our money by men paying
her to shut up
go away boy wow that's genius
she's mom like an auntie yeah and then
pay me to go away she gave one of our
younger friends a dance first and just
the dirty talking with the Vietnamese
accent give it to me give it to me give
it to me you lie my [ __ ] honey and I'm
just like like if she was like grabbing
his hands but you like my pity huh so
sexy I'm just sitting there like god I
can't imagine like I keep me matching my
[ __ ] aunt like I'm pretty sure
there's some 50 year old white guys that
like salivate for that bad that [ __ ]
me so horny I give you anything you want
they're like oh yeah like she actually
banks on these dudes she knows what
she's doing
and then so she'll go in there late on
that dude imagine she walks away she has
like a British accent oh my god be
amazing these [ __ ] hold on
do you like me to touch your bra she
extra Vietnamese is a yeah
money they're like the more rich the
guys want a rap band I put my ass on you
would you guys be down on all of us go
together to a strip club
hell naw the hardness be weird
I don't think Joe would be hard from
that ok hard on edge yeah I don't get I
don't I don't know why do they want to
call with this thing I don't know
because I don't like strip clubs I
wouldn't even go to a burlesque show
I'll go to a burlesque show I won't have
like hella like really really
entertaining [ __ ] up because these
girls are on drugs and you guys are
exploiting women
ok sisters I'm gonna see who you fall if
you follow any other bottle strippers oh
[Laughter]
no I don't want to do that
burlesque ok because when we went to
Crazy Horse all those that shit's art
I'll pay for that when I was 20 years
old no 21 my friends took me to a strip
club and I was like this is the saddest
[ __ ] on earth my dick don't get hard and
after 10 minutes I don't like to tell
you no more I don't like this what's
gonna happen next you know what if we go
to like a top not to one though the
thing is I enjoy porn and jacking off
and if I see too many naked girls it's
too normal
and I go no no more go ahead you you
guys do that and before you know it
you'll be watching some pegging porn and
all kind of weird
I'm trying to keep myself innocent the
chicks on up
I want to I want to preserve my
innocence so I can enjoy you know
preserve your innocence
[Laughter]
[Music]